are we living in some unpredictable
times meaning one moment everybody says
oh NFP is the way to go next thing you
know no one's talking about a sales are
down 94 one minute Bitcoin is going to a
half a million dollars next thing you
know Bitcoin drops fifteen thousand
dollars FTX a 32 billion dollar company
goes out of business the seal resigns oh
one minute it's gonna be a red wave next
minute is it's a very unpredictable time
that people don't know what to do so
what do you do during a time like this
the only thing you can do during a time
like this is to recreate yourself to
become better at strategies identity
with new skill set going into 2023 so
you can increase your market value
because if you don't the more market and
things change the lower your valuation
will be in the marketplace so if it's
important to you to increase your market
value we're running a sale right now for
Black Friday and Cyber Monday with every
one of our courses every one of our Live
Events if you haven't yet picked up any
of these on Black Friday Cyber Monday
click on the link above or below go get
registered I'll see you there